what's up guys we've done three reviews
of the good doctor already but we
haven't even seen season two yet so
let's start it up season 2 episode 1 dr.
Shawn I'm coming for you
the patient is pulmonary hypertension
the only treatment is medication which
reduces the lung blood pressure but not
enough her heart's failing due to the
extra string so pulmonary hypertension
is exactly what it sounds like pulmonary
meaning lungs hypertension meaning high
blood pressure but it gets really tricky
when you have high blood pressure within
the lungs because then it puts a lot of
strain on your heart to be able to beat
against that pressure within the lungs
oftentimes once medication fails the
last approach becomes surgical
intervention which is what I expect to
happen here when I say surgical
intervention means a transplant what
about a fix isn't it just a transplant
nope there's nothing inherently wrong
with Melanie's heart it's healthy just
needs a little bit of help so we're
gonna leave her current heart inside and
slot in another one to support it
well it's still a transplant you tricked
this man I obviously don't take surgical
cases like this this is outside of my
wheelhouse but it is interesting to hear
that this is even a possibility you can
have two hearts beating simultaneously
to give it a little extra support you
probably would have to be on blood
thinning medication immunosuppressive
medications because you have more
turbulent blood flow you have another
organ inside of you that your body will
probably react to unless you have
immunosuppressive medication and I could
see a huge challenge coming up here do
you live in a tent I lived in a tent -
it wasn't very good so I moved to a bus
you should move to a bus it will be much
less likely to develop all sort of tinea
pedis
tinea pedis or Pettis as he says it is a
fungal infection of the feet when it
becomes very severe you can have
ulcerative fungal infection where you
actually have breakages in the skin and
you can get infections on top of the
fungal infection you already have
present it's basically like the worst
form of athlete's foot treatment for
this usually requires oral antifungal
medication because topical would not
have the enough strength to cover it
just keep it dry and clean and we'll
give you some rather we continue to
discuss this inside we are discussing
things with the patient that are
potentially sensitive we don't weigh the
patient he's actually really right here
even though the fact he's usually bad at
picking up social cues you should not
talk about sensitive issues in front of
other people with a patient like this
even if it's as simple as putting up two
little curtains to give them some
privacy or at least a sense of privacy
will make the conversation go a lot
smoother and allow the patients to take
in the information without feeling like
all eyes on them good job Sean excuse me
please
[Music]
scuse me please thank you for keeping me
waiting we doctors are busy important
people hold on a second is that dr.
Cuddy from house is this like a
crossover event that's happening right
now
look dr. plays I am like any other
patient entitled to have say my own
treatment but unlike any other patient I
have spent my entire adult life digging
into people's brains so if you think I'm
gonna sit around and watch you're
mistaken well if you think you can
operate on yourself I'd happily add you
to the list of potential surgeons today
you're gonna be waiting and waiting and
waiting the test test test you've had
them all before I want them again my
versions actually really important what
she's doing here is that she's not
letting herself be bullied into making
medical decisions based on just what he
wants she's letting her own clinical
experience her knowledge guide her to
make the best decisions for his health
very often this happens when you have a
powerful patient a VIP patient someone
very wealthy but they say oh I want the
absolute best care I want all the tests
when in reality that's not in their best
interest and it takes someone with a lot
of guts to stand up to that so I applaud
dr. Blais / dr. Cuddy
what's your name Harry these are my
mates those pills are for people with
chlamydia
Harry no they're all the same see I I
know better that's why I had to hide out
in the street next door to mr. googly
eyes why are doctors involved in this
and not security staff like if I'm going
to any kind of event they usually bring
security with us because there's a lot
of medical equipment here there's
medications why are the doctors getting
involved come on Joe get some diesel
security dudes and gals and up and
they're just I trust him
disorganized thinking paranoia and
delusions I think you have schizophrenia
Harry okay this is my first time I'm
gonna call BS on dr. Shawn as a surgeon
perhaps you can look at someone and
figure out the problem right away
because it's a problem of plumbing
Anatomy what have you he can look at a
scan
you can't treat humans with mental
issues like that say this patient is
just high on methamphetamine and he's
having all of this disorganized
psychotic thinking is that schizophrenia
no it's not so dr. Shawn pumped those
brakes and let a non-surgical doctor
take over here
that's an abscess that smells very bad
so the reason why abscess II smell bad
is because you have an infection that
already smells bad but then you have all
these inflammatory cells that go in to
fight off the infection and what your
body does is it walls off that infection
and it essentially creates a bubble of
pus and pus never smells good because of
the dead bacteria the only treatment
Ind incision and drainage cut that bad
boy open let it drain out get the
infection out and then you could start
thinking about antibiotics and all that
but you have to drain it this would give
me at least 10 more years should give
you 10 more years yes Elliot I
understand your concerns dr. meléndez is
one of the best cardiac surgeons around
dr. Andrews told us all about you and he
convinced me to come here for surgery
instead you spoke to dr. Andrews and
they both already spent half the morning
raving to the press
well it's that's very kind you spoke to
the press he spoke to the patient my
patient as I explained Elliot Melanie
the press attention is a necessary
element for funding this surgery there's
a fine line with doing this type of
press and exposure and I understand that
line very well because I try and balance
my professional life as well as my life
as a social media person very diligently
to put it nicely sometimes medical
systems forget about that line they
forget about that the major mission that
we're involved in is helping humans and
while yes we want to get a better
surgical center so we can help more
people we want to create funding for a
hospital notoriety for a hospital the
question needs to be asked is at what
cost
do we discuss this with our patient are
they on board with having this type of
press happening is this fair to them are
we taking advantage of them and only
until you answer those questions only
then you can go ahead and do all this
press and notoriety for your hospital
ah my god is he having meningitis it's
stiff it's definite could be an early
indicator of bacterial meningitis many
possible explanations for stiff neck
most of which are much more likely than
bacterial meningitis has invaded the
meninges of his brain it could be
exacerbating his paranoia
so bacterial meningitis is inflammation
of the meninges the soft flow of padding
that's found between your brain and the
skull this is quite dangerous because
the area inside your skull is very
limited so that if you increase pressure
you could actually harm the brain and do
damage to the brain on top of that that
infection can spread from the meninges
to the actual brain to your blood and
cause you to become septic it's a very
dangerous condition that needs to be
treated
urgently the way you diagnose it is you
go into the spinal cord through a lumbar
puncture and you see and you study the
the spinal tap so you see if there's
white blood cells there if there's
bacteria in there you do a culture if
there's blood and it basically points
you to if there is a meningitis what
could be the possible cause of it and
then right away you got to start being
as proactive as possible starting all
the treatments and backing down once you
have the guidance as to what the likely
cause of the meningitis is hey
not only hasn't they already can you ISM
to ours beating into that yeah that's so
good so I've talked about aortic
aneurisms on this channel in the past
but basically what happens is the aorta
is the major blood vessels that comes
out from the heart that allows it to
bring blood to the rest of the body if
you have an aneurysm you basically have
a weakness within the wall that allows
ballooning of the last layer of the
artery which means what if you have more
pressure meaning two hearts beating at
the same time you could actually rupture
the aorta and what happens you bleed out
internally and you die perhaps they can
fix the aortic aneurysm first and then
do the procedure
I don't know how critical this patient
is right now it was my medical opinion
that he could have bacterial meningitis
and if you're right then I owe you an
apology but if you're wrong then I will
be on the phone to Denver and I will
make your life infinitely more
complicated than you think you're making
mine why is this such a manipulative
situation for God's sakes there's a
patient's life at stake who could have
bacterial meningitis you're saying if
the doctors wrong by playing it safe
you're gonna give them a bad review I
feel that one of two things is gonna
occur one it's gonna be viral or aseptic
meningitis which can happen or two by
bringing him in and doing all of these
things they're gonna find out that he
has another issue that had he not
brought him in he would have passed
let's see if my prediction is right mary
has kaleidoscopic disintegration he does
know he has a brain tumor
[Music]
this is why you said patients to the ER
because in the ER with all those
symptoms in addition to getting a spinal
tap they would have done a head CT and
likely done it with contrast to see
what's going on inside the brain and
would have seen something like a brain
tumor but I don't know what
kaleidoscopic disintegration means even
if he's right with the brain tumor this
is a guessing game that's not how
medicine is practiced kind of a shame to
see this because in season one they were
so medically accurate and making these
diagnoses and how it happens but here
just because he's finding some symptoms
and he's getting these wild theories did
you do a drug screen
did you see if he's anemic did you see
if he has a major thyroid tumor causing
excess thyroid hormone and that's why
he's bouncing around all over the place
there's a lot of things that need to be
ruled out Sean have you seen Harry he
lives in it we need to find here you
don't know so those who are diagnosed
with autism sometimes have a condition
where if there's over stimulation
whether it's light sounds even stress
they can sometimes be overwhelmed like
this I totally sympathize with Sean
what's happening here because he's
trying to do the best for his patient
but clearly it's a struggle
you have a neurological condition too
but yours can be cured
I appreciate the sentimental value here
but he doesn't know that what if it's a
malignant tumor you just need some
surgery and you can be Edward Austin
Thomas again you just need some surgery
just some surgery nice someone pay
attention to the monitors on the show
she's flatlining there they haven't even
made the incision yet and she's already
flatlining Edward has a right parietal
brain tumor
find dr. Lim you can have a war number
two that's not an emergency operation
when you need surgery you can go one of
two routes you can go planned or you can
go emergent surgery for example if you
come in with a level one trauma where
you got shot or cut inside your abdomen
and you need to find the source to bleed
and shut that off
that's emergent surgery you're not going
to get a lot of pre testing done to make
sure the patient's capable to get
through that surgery because they'll die
otherwise so you want to just do as best
as you can in the given moment but in
this scenario this is not urgent this
patient has lived for a while with this
tumor and been fine perhaps it's best to
do some pre-surgical testing figure out
if we can optimize them medically
meaning get them on some medications
lower their blood sugar control their
blood pressure clean them up now we just
have to wait to see who wakes up and
Werner Harry see that is realistic there
are certain tumors depending on where
they're found inside your brain that can
totally change certain aspects of the
way you behave for example the frontal
lobe is what's most important for
decision-making and control over your
urges so it's not uncommon for a patient
who has a frontal lobe tumor to start
acting differently becoming more risk
tolerant meaning that they're gambling
more they're having more sexual
relations unprotected cheating on their
spouses and then no one knows what's
going on only until they get properly
examined so they find out that has this
tumor the whole time
it's just like playing surgeon simulator
just drop it it's a little good heart
check out this playlist of me running
around the streets answering people's
questions curbside consults tile click
it and I'll see you on this one being
happy and healthy
[Music]